Welcome back everyone, Maximum Effort
There's a brand new Deadpool 3 teaser
that was just released this week
It features a couple of new characters from the comics
and reveals some more details about the plot.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're going to be getting a trailer at the Super Bowl,
probably.
Of course, I'll do a video
for whatever they wind up releasing.
I cannot wait to see what the marketing campaign for
this movie is like.
If you've seen Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
just go at each other in public over
other regular stuff like non movie stuff,
it's hilarious.
wow. Got Mr.
Lively. Couldn't be here
but because there are a bunch of different variants
in the scenes that they just released.
I'm going to specifically mention which versions
are the main ones for Wolverine and Deadpool.
They'll make it way easier for casual fans
in the actual movie
to tell who the main versions are
and who all the other variants are.
Do not worry about the logic getting too confusing
having to follow it, even though Deadpool
I am sure will clown on that
as he has in previous movies like so many timelines.
Who are you talking about?
This is confusing,
But the new footage starts with the main versions
of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in Deadpool,
talking to a new Deadpool variant.
They have dog poop from the comics in the scene too.
confirming all the theories that they were going to be
doing a version of the Deadpool core from the comics.
The Deadpool core is kind of like the spider
forced from Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse
with a bunch of different versions of the character
from different universes.
But it's meant to be way crazier
than the spider force was in across the spider-verse.
Even though they did get really crazy,
like they had Spider Rex in the spider buggy.
Like there are so many in the background there
you could rewatch that movie a hundred times
and still find Easter eggs in the background.
expect the same situation in Deadpool three,
but with Deadpool variants really hoping
we see a version of Galactic four.
Cannot wait to see that,
but we haven't seen the main version of Galactus,
so I'm not going to hold my breath for Galactic poor.
in what they've done in this scene
is they have the main version of Deadpool
being played by Ryan Reynolds stunt double.
That's why it looks a little different, those.
Just use CG to swap Ryan Reynolds face onto him
later in.
He's meant to be the one without his mask on.
It has all the scars from his cancer.
this is meant to tell you
which Deadpool is the main one during this movie,
when the Deadpool corps are all on screen,
like you have all these different variants
in some of their suits look kind of similar,
but you can usually tell by looking at their suits too,
like this is what the suit for.
The main version of Deadpool looks like He's meant to
be the Deadpool from the original main X-Men universe.
They canonize the main X-Men universe
to the Deadpool movies during Deadpool two,
even though we have a whole bunch of X-Men characters
coming back like Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine coming back as more comic book
version of Wolverine, all the other versions,
including that Hugh Jackman
Wolverine are from completely different universes.
Vanessa and Doe
Pindar are both coming back from Deadpool two.
I'm assuming that they're the only other people
from that original main X-Men universe
the rest of the movie is him in other universes.
We only have the main version of Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine here interacting
with the other Deadpool variant.
But I'm not sure
which universe dog pool is meant to be.
From.
part of the joke here, though,
is that he is a version of Deadpool from his universe,
like he is the main version of Deadpool,
the only version of Deadpool really,
even though he just looks like a little dog
with the Deadpool outfit on, he actually does have
Deadpool regeneration powers In the comics, Dog
Paul is from like a totally alternate universe.
end, in that universe, his origin story is a bit
of a parody of the main 616 version of Deadpool.
So he's owned by mascara X,
which is a parody of the Weapon
X program, who use them as a guinea pig
to test all their cosmetics on.
it is meant to be a parody of the weapon X program.
Experimenting on Wolverine Deadpool two.
But Deadpool is technically from the Weapon K program,
which is like an offshoot of Weapon X.
through those experiments, dog pool mutated,
giving him the power to heal himself.
He almost died.
And then mascara X basically didn't have any more
use for him, so they threw him in a dumpster,
but his regeneration powers saved him and he joined
the circus doing all kinds of crazy stunts
because he could heal himself
eventually the main 616 Deadpool came across universes,
found him
and recruited him to the Deadpool corps in the comics.
He winds up being befriended by Kid Paul.
They might just change that and say that
the main version of Deadpool here, like Ryan Reynolds,
Deadpool is the one that befriends him
because he's carrying him around here.
Just because Ryan Reynolds is always posting
those funny commercials for the brands
that he owns, like the cell phone brand
or the gin brand.
they should actually do a funny commercial
about dog paws origin with this whole products company,
but do it as a funny commercial for the movie,
as if it's an actual trailer.
Speaking of which, very apropos.
Thank you to Rea Con for sponsoring this week's video.
If you've been on YouTube before,
you probably heard of Ray Con.
They made a name for themselves
in the premium audio space.
their everyday earbuds.
They've been incredibly successful.
Their everyday overear headphones tech kids
their home tech kids like their faucet
filter room purifier.
Their magic charging cable
So to thank everyone who's shown them support,
They're offering a special discount
on all their products.
Sitewide using my code.
I'll put it up here on screen.
And second, so this is the perfect time to get yourself
some products
that made Ray Collins
so well known like their everyday earbuds.
Their everyday earbuds are known for delivering high
quality audio and thoughtful features like a 32 hour
battery life, a perfect in-ear fit for all day
wear and lasting comfort.
different sound modes
depending on what you're using them for.
My pure sound for more casual listening, balanced
sound for more warmth and depth,
a special enhanced bass mode special noise
isolation modes for blocking outside noise.
And each pair comes with a charging case
for on the go charging.
All of this for half the price of other premium brands,
which is the reason
they've racked up over 78,005 star reviews.
Generally, I've been using Ray Con every day earbuds
because I haven't found another pair of earbuds
that are is convenient
and as small as the ray con earbuds,
these are just like the perfect earbuds
when you're on the go or doing a quick casual workout
and you just need something small convenient to carry
around without taking up too much pocket space.
so if you're just looking for earbuds
that are really convenient and won't break your bank
I highly recommend
you get yourself a pair just click on my link
in the description or type it in your browser.
Go to a by Ray Cotton dot com slash emergency.
Awesome and get an additional 15% off
sitewide and free shipping.
So be sure to check it out.
the other member of the Deadpool Accord that it looks
like they run into on the beach here where the scene is
taking place is a long haired version with no scars
on his face in super hardcore looking armor.
he also seems super happy, like he's
just joking around with Wolverine.
I think part of the joke here is that he's
meant to be a version of Deadpool,
like a random Deadpool corps member
who's super handsome in perfect.
Like his life was great.
He never got cancer,
so his face looks way more handsome.
You like the Fabio perfect looking version of Deadpool,
the most idealized version of Deadpool
in the probably just use the scene
so that Ryan Reynolds can clown on himself
for being super fugly
like you're the worst version of Deadpool
There are a couple meta jokes at the beginning
of the first Deadpool movie during the opening credits
where they were clowning on Ryan Reynolds in real life
for being the world's most handsome person
it also seems like one of the other jokes here
is that Wolverine really likes
this perfect looking version of Deadpool,
but he hates the main version of Deadpool.
Can't stand him.
I did a video a while ago
when they released the footage,
but a big part of their initial meeting,
it seems like, is Wolverine trying to kill him
because he can't stand Deadpool
and he won't leave him alone.
it's not totally clear
where this new scene is happening in the movie
or if it's taking place on the battle world
that the TVA starts creating.
My only theory right now is is just meant to be
the same void planet it from the Loki series
because we're talking about TVA characters here
like there were TVA characters in the footage
that they released a little while ago.
in I think, you know, early theory here is
that is on this planet that Deadpool and Wolverine
wind up teaming up with a bunch of their variants
like this Deadpool dog pool the Deadpool
core to fight a bunch of evil X-Men characters
in other Fantastic Four characters from the Fox
Marvel movies that we saw in all those other scenes
like Deadpool Kills the Fox Marvel Universe.
So it's all a bunch of characters cameos
from those movies or characters
that are based on people from those movies.
they're couple other scenes of them here
on the same planet where Deadpool has his mask on.
This might be before they run into the other Deadpool
core members and these other versions of Deadpool.
As far as I know, the way they're explained.
The other Wolverine variants in the movie,
though, is it?
They'll mostly be in the other universes that Deadpool
hops through as he finds this version of Wolverine.
I think the bit they're doing
with this version of the character is
they're saying that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
here is meant to be the perfect version of Wolverine.
It is meant to clown on Kevin
by recasting all the X-Men characters
like Deadpool is looking for versions of Wolverine,
and he winds up
finding out that Hugh
Jackman's is the perfect version of Wolverine.
Like he'll never be able to recast me in real life
because he's perfect.
even though we know Kevin Bogey is doing a new live
action X-Men movie in the MCU, I think that Mr.
Sinister is actually supposed
to be in the main villain of that,
but that's not meant to be super connected
to what's happening in Deadpool three.
Deadpool three is mostly just setting up
what's happening with Avengers Secret
Wars, all that live action X-Men stuff
I think is going to be a little bit separate.
But they did say that they weren't
going to debut the new MCU version of Wolverine
till way after secret wars.
Like after they're completely done with Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and he'll be back for secret wars
I think once the dust from Avengers Secret Wars settles
in, they reboot into whatever the main MCU
is going to be like a more comic book
looking version of the 616 universe.
Ryan Reynolds will probably be one of the only people
from those Fox Marvel movies
who survived as his original version
of the character into the new movies
Like eventually there will be an MCU
version of Wolverine, played by a different actor. But.
I think what's going on in this movie
with all the Deadpool core members is that it's mostly
going to be a bunch of Deadpool variants in not that
many Wolverine variants like maybe just a couple.
I did a video about x 23 coming back.
Supposedly she's going to be in the movie somewhere,
but I don't know if it's going to be on this planet
or some other part of the movie,
and for most of the movie is just going to be
these two main versions
running around facing all of the other characters.
I think all the Deadpool core stuff.
Is this going to be for part of the movie?
we're supposed to get the first legit trailer
at the Super Bowl.
Whatever they wind up releasing.
Of course, I'll do a video for it.
I think they'll be done filming all the reshoots
and the extra stuff that they're doing right now.
Pretty soon,
just because the movie's coming out this summer.
So they will start releasing a bunch of footage
really soon.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up this week,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
Click here for that other new Deadpool
three trailer and click here
to watch Wolverine and Sabretooth go at each other.
Thank you so much for watching and maximum effort!